[Music]
here we are once again and we are back
happy sunday happy father's day i
totally forgot it was father's day until
somebody said something
yeah i'm gonna call her daddy's name hi
what
oh yeah i don't know it that's how i'm
going to send him some turkey necks
yeah my dad's response to how you been i
don't know
it that's his is that he always yeah i
don't know
how am i supposed to know
why you even asking me yeah i told tom
that uh pookie should have got him a
father's day video that would have been
really funny yeah i was i was thinking
about it
looks like everybody looks like
everybody's here in the comments section
even t-shir
t showed up on time can't believe it
did you start spartacus yet see he's
just gonna see how i'm gonna [ __ ] with
you
did you start spartacus yet did you see
uh did you see
uh bronson yet did you see
mitch never did go in there and check
[ __ ] superman red sun
i see how it is she don't want to watch
animated stuff i understand
tila said my uncle says i can't call it
when i ask him how is it how
it it's a southern is is he southern
they [ __ ] have the craziest responses
to [ __ ]
the more the deeper you go into the
[ __ ] backwoods the crazier [ __ ] that
they say they make up little phrases and
stuff
it's kind of endearing you know they do
that [ __ ] that's it tila says she's in
the middle of watching bronson now so
shut up
yeah yeah bronte's cool huh brian's good
i think it's good what do you make of it
so far
we're uh we're talking about another
movie today
this is the second installation in m
night
shaman's unbreakable trilogy yeah
in his superhero trilogy which
um i gotta say
m knight when he's in form man he's good
when he's out of for me [ __ ] sucks um
yeah there's really no in between is
there
but this was the only movie out of that
trilogy that i haven't seen and i gotta
say
his superhero trilogy is a masterpiece
it's a masterpiece of low budget
movie making this is not big budget he's
making a superhero
movie or a whole universe
superhero universe out of nothing
with no money and i think it's very
successful
i like it i kind of feel like m knight
is more in his element
with more with smaller more grounded
stories like this
is about superheroes and stuff well i
feel like when he he fails when he tries
to go too
big or too elaborate with the world
building yeah you know what i mean it
seems like most of the movies of his
that i liked
were ones that were you know smaller in
scope like and character driven like
this one was
yeah now i will say so it's like so i've
seen unbreakable
probably two or three times we saw glass
in the theater when it came out
but i had never seen split either so
this was the first time
seeing it like i kind of knew what it
was about and like i said since you'd
seen
since we'd already seen glass you know
it kind of refers back to that one
i have to say and this this may be a
controversial uh opinion but now that
i've seen split i actually like split
better than unbreakable
i liked unbreakable too i'm not saying
that but i'm just saying i think i like
split the best of all three of them
i like them all this is a super villain
movie
yeah it's it's in the same universe
[ __ ] mr glasses mentioned and
surprised cameo at the very end
bruce willis playing i guess it's his
version of the superhero
and uh the the main character in this
story is a villain
and uh if he's called the horde
and he comes across as kind just like a
demented serial killer
and you think he's [ __ ] out of his
mind
you're not really sure i mean if you
didn't know this was linked in with the
unbreakable
universe you would think he was just
crazy but at the end he
manifests paranormal abilities
and what i like about this is that this
entire
universe his version of a superheroes
universe what i like about it
is that it's grounded in reality what if
that [ __ ] was true what would it really
look like
and that's what this is about you could
almost say that maybe that
that paranormal one with the kid that
saw the ghost what was the name of that
[ __ ]
the sixth sense you you could
you might be able to say that the sixth
sense might have been in this same
universe
i kind of feel like a lot of his movies
are in the same universe
like if there was a kid that could talk
see dead people
and communicate with them that would
almost be like a
super power too it'd be like something
doctor strange or mrs fisto might be
able to do
well these characters are like that
but they're they're almost kind of like
some paranormal psychic
manifesting poltergeist type
abilities on the edge of what would be
real you know
me personally haven't seen a poltergeist
and been a part of a poltergeist
outbreak
if that's what you want to call it and
having some near-death and out-of-body
experiences
if there were superheroes they would be
like this
this is what they would be like it would
be something
that's what a lot of people like about
this particular series is that it's like
a superhero movie it's not like over the
top it's like
super realistic no leotards and [ __ ] and
i also well i
i think my favorite thing about split
and like i said this is the first time
that i had
seen this although i kind of they kind
of touched on it a little bit in glass
which we saw in the theater when it came
out
i really like the concept of someone
with
dissociative identity disorder and some
of their
personalities manifesting just different
physical traits
i think they even like imply this one
like one of his personalities has
diabetes and none of the other ones do
right and that one's got to take insulin
right yeah and it's like so there are
actually like physiological
like differences between which is a
fascinating thing to explore
yeah um and and him like his 24th
personality being
the beast which is essentially like a
super human
kind of like bane yeah like it looks
like he's bigger and he can like climb
up walls and like you know
bullets bounce off him and [ __ ] like
that well he he
his image of himself is that he's bigger
and has long hair he doesn't
yeah that dude's bald he's the same size
but that [ __ ] can climb up a wall
you see him do it yeah you see him
absorb a couple of shotgun blasts at
pretty close range
yep um he thinks he's huge he's not but
he is strong
it might [ __ ] run on all fours and
run up a wall
which just looks like something from
possession maybe
yeah and what what the idea here is is
that a mental disorder
can cause paranormal not only multiple
personalities but some of these
personalities have can exhibit
paranormal phenomenon it's a [ __ ]
masterpiece man i think it's like just a
great i mean what a great idea
yeah and the thing about it so
interestingly i had completely forgotten
because unbreakable came out in 2000
right yeah
this movie came out in 2016.
now at the time that it came out they
were keeping it very
closely under wraps that this was
essentially
in the same universe as unbreakable they
called it a stealth sequel
uh you know meaning this is kind of like
the first time that this had been done
so i think when m knight first showed
the movie to test audiences
he left that last scene with bruce
willis out that links it in with
unbreakable
he left that out but when they showed it
at
film like it premiered i think at the
afi film festival or something like that
and i was watching
uh chris stuckman and he saw it at the
uh film festival
and he's a big m night fan so no
so going into split not knowing that it
was supposed to be
not necessarily a sequel but in the same
universe
and so when that last scene happened and
then you know bruce willis is there and
he said
said something about mr glass he's like
the [ __ ] the whole audience like
[ __ ]
lost their [ __ ] yeah i i did too i
wasn't expecting that
yeah i knew they were part of the same
yeah see back then they didn't know
right like so i imagine it was a huge
there was a badass everybody's like
yeah that would have been a badass
um that i mean what did i say that's a
badass rev
reveal yeah see shanlin had this [ __ ]
he was the twist
guy and that kind of was his problem
he [ __ ] that up a couple times but
that
ending to this movie was a [ __ ]
fantastic reveal slash twist
and it wasn't really a twist it was a
reveal yeah but it was
a brilliant review if you did reveal if
you didn't know this is part of the
unbreakable series
like you said the audience didn't you
had been oh it all makes sense now
yeah you're like oh yeah that's [ __ ]
bad because it was interesting watching
reviews for people that saw it at the
time
uh that it came out and didn't know you
know that it was that because they saw
it like at a film festival and stuff
and they were just kind of like they
really liked it because they're like oh
he's exploring kind of the same thing
like a superhero super villain really uh
origin story but they didn't really
think about it as being tied in with uh
unbreakable and they're like but if you
didn't know that it was tied in with
unbreakable when they get to the part
near the end where james mcavoy starts
like being the beast and he starts like
climbing up the walls and stuff
and a few people were kind of like well
i don't know if i'm buying this anymore
because it was like so realistic but
then like that last scene they were like
oh
okay well now it makes it's a super
villain movie
yeah i thought it was just a masterful
movie the acting's [ __ ] great
james mcavoy should have got a [ __ ]
oscar nomination at least
i can't believe he didn't get one for
this he was incredible
he plays about six or seven different
personalities and they're all credible
you see him as a different person in a
way it doesn't seem like he's acting it
just seems like he's mentally ill
yeah it's a very natural performance
real natural the way it happens
i mean i always like james back boy
anyway that's fantastic real good
but he was just he was amazing in this
yeah amazing now it makes me want to see
glass again
no uh what's the last one the last one
is yeah i want to see glass i've only
seen it once
so we have it right i have it yeah i
have it we have unbreakable and we have
glass we ordered split but it hasn't
come yet
i think we just watched it on amazon
prime and i got a [ __ ] sneaking
suspicion it's coming from the uk i got
a sneaking
suspicion that it's [ __ ] the wrong
reason that we're not gonna be able yeah
see you really gotta watch that kind of
[ __ ] because it wasn't so it specified i
went back and looked at the ad and it
does not specify
it doesn't say that it doesn't play it
doesn't say because most of the time in
uh if you look at the amazon things like
a lot of them will have a little message
at the bottom like hey
heads up this problem won't play like on
most north american [ __ ]
right but not always so you gotta watch
like sometimes
i kind of feel like and a lot of
reviewers said this about split as well
because as i said a lot of people had
been you know kind of
you know everybody loved unbreakable a
lot of people liked signs
but then kind of after that he did he
went into kind of like a slump where a
lot of his movies were like really
poorly reviewed like to such an extent
that he
sort of became uh you know a whipping
boy for a long time and people would
like
a joke almost but then when this came
out
i feel like the critics were like oh
he's he's back you know
because this movie is like [ __ ]
awesome i agree and the fact that it was
that he snuck it in there that it was
like a sequel a stealth sequel to
unbreakable you know 16 years later
because he i think what ended up
happening was that the character
that james mcavoy plays whose real name
is kevin even though he has like 23 24
different personalities
um i think that m knight had actually
written that character
to go into unbreakable initially like
back in
you know the late 90s or whatever and
he's just like well as that movie
you know progressed i just took that
character out but i still
kept all those pieces and that's kind of
what he made split out of yeah because
it would be hard to stuff
this character into that movie yeah into
that first movie this move this
character requires a movie of its own
which that's what they did
it's brilliant and then in the third one
they kind of like all three of them are
you could take you could take this
trilogy and then
this trilogy and um the sixth sense and
that together would be uh
i'm just gonna say that that's enough to
to call a guy to say that a guy had a
brilliant career
i think that just say you know that's my
opinion
he did have some some people say signs
is good
i think science is kind of mediocre
actually um
but just this trilogy alone i'm going to
call it a masterpiece
i mean i think it's better than the mcu
i'm not i'm not impressed with the mcu
in terms
because it's it's just visually driven
it's like going on a roller coaster ride
they don't it's very generic to me it's
not really
any kind of deep storytelling in it it's
not a lot of lore in it
it didn't none of the mcu really kind of
personally [ __ ] communicated anything
deep to me
i would say john wick movies
[ __ ] were deeper than the mcu i liked
the john wick and to me that was saying
something a little bit you know
his dog or whatever and it was fun
movies to watch
i could remember them when they were
over i couldn't even remember an mcu
movie was over
yeah and i'm not and i'm not like
[ __ ] on people because i know people
are like super super into the mcu and
like they've seen all the movies and i
have to say i haven't seen all the
movies
i've seen like a selection of them but
well i mean as a whole
like i said if people like them that's
cool i'm just i'm not a real like ooh
big spectacle movie type person
um to me they're very corporate and very
genuine yeah so it's like i enjoy them
when i watch them but then i can't
really remember
the details from time to time you don't
walk out of there with like a
new perspective on anything they don't
change you at all that's true you know
what i mean and a story's gotta [ __ ]
kind of at least put you in an altered
state
when when you're walking out yeah i just
kind of see them as they're just like
fun popcorn movies yeah it's just like a
roller coaster ride you go okay that's
it it's over and then it didn't really
change anything
yeah i mean like i said i know some
people got super into it and that's
you know that's cool but like i said i'm
not a real big like spectacle
just saying that is not cinema
the mcu is not cinema the joker was
you know the joker the joker was a
[ __ ] great movie that you know the uh
there was a few of them that were really
good you know that first two seasons of
first two seasons of [ __ ] daredevil
maybe even the third season of daredevil
is really good yeah if you're gonna do
superheroes i tend to like a more kind
of
toned down yeah realistic kind of take
on them
you know what i mean this one right here
this trilogy and bright burn
went would go together pretty well it
seemed bright burn felt like it was in
this universe
it did a little bit didn't it a little
bit yeah tila asked which
uh which of the movies was our favorite
from the three
i'm gonna say having and i've just seen
split once like last night or then or
it wasn't last night was the night
before um i'm gonna say i think split is
my favorite
uh you know i'd have to watch all of
them again i like i like it actually a
little bit better than unbreakable
just because i that that [ __ ]
performance like james mcavoy there
that's just like [ __ ]
even if it was just that even if there
wasn't all the stuff about the
kidnapping the girls and like the whole
hit like all of his personalities and
his interaction
with his um therapist who's played by
betty buckley
like all that [ __ ] is like so so good
and there's and it's like funny too but
it's not
i don't know i think he really hit like
the humor
scary balance like really well in this
movie
which he doesn't always do but i think
he really got it in this one
the horde the horde is a bunch of
different characters the guy's got
multiple personalities
yeah so
it is kind of a deep character into
itself and they're all talking to each
other and they're all trying to
negotiate with each other
and they're all trying to get into the
light yeah to be like the front person
be the front one
yeah which is kind of a great setup for
a villain
yeah it thinks it sees itself for the
[ __ ] you know the horde sees itself as
a multitude
it's kind of like demonic possession
where they say we're a legion or i am
legion yeah it's like that
some of them are good and some of them
are bad and the good ones can come
forward and they kind of act as
camouflage for the bad ones
it's kind of well and they're trying to
kind of like wrestle control one of the
best things about it
is that there's really only i mean the
beast who's obviously like
the villain villain because he's like
has the paranormal abilities but then
you have
dennis who is kind of like a btk
type kidnap he's the one that kidnaps
the girls so he's obviously a bad guy
then you have patricia who is this royal
kind of uppercussed
older lady and she's kind of like the
mom but she also kind of
is in cahoots with dennis yeah and then
you have hedwig who's a nine-year-old
kid
and he seems like he's real friendly and
[ __ ] like that but then in the end he
kind of like throws his lot in with the
bad guys too just because
um he thinks that the beast is going to
protect all of them but it's interesting
that some of the personalities like
barry and stuff like that are trying to
rest control back from like the bad
personalities yeah you know what i'm
saying so i think that's like a really
good
in totality though you can just say the
horde is one thing
yeah and that the good ones are kind of
like camouflage for the bad ones
they're all acting together as a team
ultimately and behind it all is this
damn beast
yeah and i think that's really what it
is the horde is actually the beast
because it was the highest culmination
of them all remember yeah they came up
out of the it came up out of the group
um so they're all kind of giving excuses
for one another but
you wouldn't want to mess with the horde
no be very dangerous
[Laughter]
you know um
because in the end it's just in a way it
just ends up deceiving you anyway
behind all that is the is that beast and
i mean though
the one the couple scenes where because
you know a couple of the personalities
are like sending emails to
the therapists like without the other
ones knowing yeah like being like help
me help me
and then but they won't say which one it
is and i love
that he turns up at the therapist office
saying that he's barry which is usually
the person
the persona that he friends with when
he's there at the uh that it's like he's
supposed to be like the kind of
spokesperson or whatever
but it's actually dennis fronting as
barry
like that's another personality so it's
like really complicated but you could
also read it this way
the the the entities inside the horde
that was asking for help
that was really just another way of
reaching out to contact a victim
to to bait him in well ultimately
ultimately
that happened that's why all of them
would be dangerous yeah it's all the
whole thing is dangerous it's just part
of it's
kind of like the thing it can be
whatever it needs to be at the time
yeah in the end it's going to try to
absorb you or kill you be like that
or eat you but i mean he ate those two
girls yeah and
like a lion yeah you know yeah
t was asking which is the best one it's
hard to say because each one built on
the other ones
um even though i i didn't see split
in the theater i didn't see it i saw a
glass without seeing split
yeah and i thought that glass was better
than unbreakable
it was pretty cool i didn't know who the
horde was but it's in that movie yeah
but you it gives you enough information
in
in there to where you don't have to see
split but i wish i would have seen split
before yeah it would have been good to
see that would have been yeah
i mean we were i think i remember before
we went to see glass i said oh we should
see split
before we see glass because i think it's
like a it's a trilogy and then we just
didn't get around to it
right which one is best it's hard to say
i mean each one is kind of offering its
own thing
unbreakable was cool because it
introduces to you as a person in the
audience the idea that a superhero
might actually exist that superheroes
and super villains might actually exist
what they what would they be like
and bruce willis is kind of like his
character is introducing you into this
you know that he touches someone he can
kind of get an idea of
if they're doing something wrong or not
you know he doesn't believe it you don't
really believe it then this you start to
believe and he starts to believe and
his powers start to get he starts
trusting himself and it actually works
and then he goes in there and tries to
do bench presses
and uh he realizes that he can bench
as much weight as he as he needs to yeah
he just keeps adding weight he can still
bench it
and i think he ended up bitching about
300 pounds yeah which was
that's a lot of weight for somebody of
bruce willis's
build well and somebody that hasn't been
training to do that
hasn't been lifted right he could lift
that he couldn't believe that he could
lift that
and then um and so it was kind of a cool
way
it wasn't unreasonable strength he
wasn't lifting a car like superman
it was within the realm of possibilities
there are guys that could do that
yeah it's just he he genetically had
these gifts
and they were kind of understandable
because um
psychometry is a supposed ability which
is where you touch something and you can
get an idea of where it came from
yeah you know a real
[ __ ] house version of that would be palm
reading that's another way
yeah you know that he should touch
someone and
go oh man that person is abusing their
child at home and get a flash
of it of a psychic flash of what they
were doing wrong if he
and if he followed his instincts he
could save people
that was a [ __ ] a very kind of
believable way of
of of expressing a superhero
and then at the end of that when you
find out that the guy who was mentoring
him the whole time
was a super villain yeah he was mr glass
he was doing all this terrorism to find
a hero
because without that he would be
meaningless now without without a hero
he you know as a villain he would be
meaningless
yeah so you have to kind of watch them
all
i guess to understand yeah they all
explore like a different aspect of the
same
kind of thing which i thought was like a
really interesting thing to do
um i would say glass was a culmination
of all of them
and in terms of action glass was the
best one
yeah a lot happened in glass i'm going
to say i'm i'm not going to say i don't
i don't i don't know if i can say which
one's the best one but my
i think split was my favorite yeah just
because that dude's like performing good
like it's just blew my top of my head
off yeah it was just like so [ __ ]
good
in glass it's all kind of coming
together into into a into a into what
you would know as what
as a superhero movie with super villains
acting together yeah and really fighting
and [ __ ]
mr roboto asked uh why the character
wasn't on medication
i think he might have been at some point
but i think that they said
in the movie that he'd actually been uh
okay for like 10 years right because
they said he had a job and he'd been
like real stable
and everything like that so i don't know
if he'd been on medication at some point
in the past and they'd weaned him off it
or if he was still on it or whatever i'm
not really sure but they did say that he
um that he had been had a stable job for
10 years and he hadn't been
doing anything bad you also got to
understand that he wasn't a normal
person
well yeah all right he was he had a
mental illness but
but it wasn't just that he had these
extraordinary gifts
all right the average per the average
mentally ill person would not end up
like this
according to mr glass remember from the
very first movie some people are gifted
he was a gifted person who happened to
have mental illness
that culminated in the creation of a
character called the beast
and he had paranormal [ __ ] abilities
it opened up a doorway
into basically
mental powers that's basically what he
said it opened
and that he became a higher
more evolved human being that that's the
way human was supposed to be
okay and that he was seeing other people
as
um what do you call them well they were
impure
impurities because they hadn't suffered
they hadn't suffered
they haven't suffered enough to unlock
this door
into you that would allow these
paranormal abilities to come out
and which is very much like nichian
philosophy
that that which does not kill you makes
you stronger that's basically what he
was saying
so he and a lot of the things that the
beast said was kind of niche ian
you know about you know suffering burns
away
impurities you know uh that goes all the
way back to zoroastrianism where you go
to hell
to burn off impurities and then you end
up becoming a clean
soul that can ascend to heaven that kind
of thinking well i mean that's why that
was the whole
uh reasoning behind him not killing
because he killed the other two girls
that he kidnapped but he didn't kill
uh anya taylor joy's character because
he saw the scars on her so she had
suffered enough
um and she was like you know she she was
able to match him
even though she couldn't kill him uh so
he let her go and then she was great in
it too by the way she was also in the
witch
uh which i think louis mentioned which
was also a fantastic movie
um yeah tila said can we talk about his
physical transformation as the beast
which
yeah and i don't even think this movie
m night paid for this movie himself just
like he did the visit it was nine
million dollars
and it made um 278 million
it was exactly it was actually the most
profitable movie
of that year of the year that it came
out uh just because
you know like i said he paid for himself
and it was only nine million dollars so
i don't know if they really used a lot
of cgi
i don't really think they did i think
james mcavoy i was gonna say that great
scene where he's like pulling the bars
apart
and like his [ __ ] face and it's like
he doesn't even look like the same
dude anymore and it's like i don't think
they did any cgi there
i mean it didn't look like it it just
looked like he was just like making a
[ __ ] crazy ass face
yeah i didn't think there was any uh
transformation it was just the way he
was moving
yeah which again that was like a [ __ ]
brilliant ass performance because even
though they didn't as far as i know they
didn't do any sort of digital effects or
anything to make him look
different but they shot him from a lower
angle to me
but you knew you knew that that was fake
because the the things around him
yeah but it's still the same size he
didn't get bigger
in his mind he was bigger yeah and uh
he was a lot stronger in his mind which
actually allowed him to do things that a
normal human couldn't do
and and he could just grip onto a wall
and climb up a wall like spider-man
yeah like a lizard yeah well he was kind
of like taking all the
beast characteristics like from because
you'd find out later that like um
they've he's been keeping he worked at a
zoo for 10 years the philadelphia zoo
and he that's where he was keeping them
like
the thing underneath she shot him at
least twice with
looked like double that buckshot from a
shotgun yeah it marked his skin up but
it didn't
it didn't penetrate him he just laughed
it off yeah he was just like whatever
yeah
so you know hard to deny that that yeah
it was a paranormal yeah i mean if i
shot a dude it wasn't just
in the [ __ ] chest and he just kind of
kept coming at me i'd be like well i
guess i'm [ __ ]
yeah it wasn't in his mind where it was
his mind but it allowed him to do that
yeah i mean the the thing about this too
and i didn't realize this and i don't
even think this is on the wikipedia page
but i just saw it on a different uh
review
was that this movie actually looks great
like the cinematography is really nice
and i found out that i can't remember
the dude's name but m night wanted the
same cinematographer that did
it follows so if you've seen it follows
and then you see this you can kind of
tell
that that's the same person that did the
cinematography because it looks
not like similar but you can tell like
it's kind of the same sort of style
but yeah i just i i'm just so mad that
it took us this long to see it and
like i said it's it sucks because i kind
of feel like i wish we would have seen
them in order
yeah um you know and and it did occur to
me like before we went to see glass it's
like oh we should probably see split
first
but we just didn't do it when you have
the blue rays there's a lot of uh
deleted seeds yeah you know unbreakable
too
and more information pretty good good
movies
yeah you're good i'd like to see a
fourth one
you could do a whole universe you could
bring that kid back from the sixth sense
and he'd be groaned now
and he'd be kind of like dr strange
yeah you'd be fighting bad guys and
talking to dead people and asking them
what's going on with that hey dead guy
yeah yeah what's up with that is
sending ghosts to do [ __ ] for you
just have him yeah have him just show up
and you go oh it's that kid from the six
he's one of them too you could combine
that one too see
he could just m nate should uh he should
just tie every single one of his movies
together yeah and
and the aliens from science too yeah you
got [ __ ] mel gibson being crazy as
[ __ ]
i mean there's got to be some way that
you could tie all those stories together
somehow yeah i mean you know what i mean
yeah mr robotta said uh he's fat now
yeah the kid that played uh oh yes
well he remember he was in tusk oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah
he was the other he's not that fat
though he's good enough to do it yeah
yeah i don't yeah i wouldn't call him
fat he's a little chubby he's a little
chubby that's all that's okay that'd be
that fit right in you know he hadn't
had him talking to the ghost he's eating
[ __ ] peanut butter jelly
yeah yeah go do the go go you know it's
okay
ghost got it covered he's gonna go take
a look he'll contact us in a minute i'm
just gonna sit back and eat some poho's
yeah yeah yeah
yeah he's got a damn tarot card shop
he's [ __ ] telling fortunes and [ __ ]
but over the people's shoulder and
the ghost telling him what uh he did
this and kind of like
kind of like that of the frighteners
yeah yeah where dude's got a team of
ghosts working for him
ghost team yeah i had a ghost team yeah
maybe i do and i don't even know about
it yeah
wouldn't that be something man i'm so
[ __ ] sleepy you guys
we went to uh mannequins you thought
that was a good idea good idea tom yeah
yeah i mean like like you said there's
really not much limit to
no because you know if if these three
people have the have these powers like
mr glass has them and like you know
bruce willis's guy has them and
[ __ ] and the beast has them it's like
well then that stands to reason that
there would be more than that
there'd be a lot be a big variety of
stuff yeah and you can't have willis
back because he gets killed in um
in in on br in glass oh yeah he did he
got killed yeah
spoiler alert but his son survived
yeah and it was kind of and it was kind
of um
hinted that there was something special
about his son too wasn't it
from what i remember well yeah because i
thought no we we saw glass
that came out in theaters what like back
in 2018 right early
2020 i can't remember but yeah we saw it
uh back then
and i kind of remember what happened in
it but not exactly like we had a big
fight
at the end of the damn parking lot yeah
okay i remember that
yeah i remember that and that [ __ ]
the horde
the beast was running on all four yeah
yeah
on all fours and jumping over cars and
[ __ ] yeah it looks really [ __ ] weird
holy [ __ ] he was down from what i
remember he was just wasn't he just in
underwear i thought he just had pants on
pants but i couldn't be
remembered yeah i thought it was just
pants orange like prison pants
he's galloping on all fours and jumping
over the car
yeah it looks like a [ __ ] dog running
that's [ __ ] yeah
yeah i don't know if that was digitally
done or if that was like i think it was
it looked good though yeah it did tila
says supervising a team of ghosts and
eating little debbies
yeah see that's what we do yeah scott
says i'd have the ghost to remove all of
the brown m
m's yeah but yeah i'm kind of sleepy
yeah we went to uh mannequins last night
the theme was goth apocalypse
yeah all although they did it friday
night too so i feel like more people
dress up on friday night i guess from
what we heard
not many people i was gonna win i was
gonna win the uh
the competition but tom says nah it's
not fair man go ahead
kick me out they were [ __ ] rooting
for me and [ __ ] i was dressed up like a
damn war boy
i got video of it yeah i was like i was
like i wanted him to get out there but i
was like well he's not gonna let you win
because
everybody's going to be like favoritism
yeah yeah because i'm damn near staff
you know that's well that's why like i
kind of i kind of wore
an out like a kind of apocalyptic
looking outfit too but it's like i
didn't even bother
like because i said i know they're not
going to give it to me
so it's like you [ __ ] can't drink
free in here get out
we already let you use the staff
bathroom what else do you want but yeah
it's kind of that
sort of thing but yeah we took uh we
took the kids
took the kids and then we'd get home
till [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i had goggles i had goggles yeah yeah
that's gonna be that somebody's gonna
gift that that would be really funny
we're gonna pump you up
yeah uh tom can win you just have to
make it look legit
what was the best costume there weren't
really like i said there weren't a lot
the girl that won i think she basically
had
what did she even have on she had like
some of these big goggles she was pretty
much like all covered up she had kind of
like
all kind of like camouflaged [ __ ] all
over and stuff like that like i said i
heard that
for what they said they said they did it
friday night too and they said that
more people had dressed up on friday
night yeah because i guess they've
started to do a theme like every weekend
now which is fine with me
i think they're doing bloodbath the next
i don't know if it's the next theme or
i don't know it was somebody wanted to
do that so everybody has to come all
covered in blood
so we'll see how that goes yeah all
right so before we get off
t you need to start on damn spartacus
man you need to learn the art of roman
treachery
okay that one will [ __ ] teach you the
the the
the roman art of [ __ ] people over
yeah it's like
some of the [ __ ] that happened in that i
was like oh that [ __ ]
yeah that [ __ ] it is really good
we haven't uh what were we on we on
season four yeah we got to do
season four we haven't we haven't done
we haven't seen season four yet i mean
we i got so much [ __ ] [ __ ] i gotta
watch yeah and then it's like i think i
just i just uh i'm gonna do a podcast
with a couple other female horror
writers at the end of july um and we're
gonna be talking about handmaid's tale
so i haven't so then now i got four
seasons of handmaid's tale that i gotta
watch because i haven't
i've been meaning to start watching that
but i haven't like watched it yet so
i'll get around to it
all right so we will be back uh tomorrow
at three o'clock
probably be talking about the lost
george romero movie
the amusement park which shutter just
added uh i think he came
he made it in 1973 but i don't know if
it ever came out so they like just
restored it and [ __ ]
and uh it was in the poll for the movie
retrospective but it tied
with hannibal rising so i said okay well
we'll do the movie retrospective we'll
do hannibal rising and then
on the matinee tomorrow we'll talk about
the georgia romero
we've already seen hannibal rising it's
one of my favorite movies yeah so we'll
just like
i mean i've seen it a couple of times
but we'll like re-watch it tonight and
we can talk about tomorrow and then
we'll watch the um
the george romero one tonight as well
and then we'll talk about that
tomorrow at three o'clock so thank you
everybody for dropping by have a good
rest of your weekend happy father's day
to all the fathers out there
and we will see you guys tomorrow bye